what are you stuffing monkey where are
we going to California yeah and what do
you putting in your backpack I'm putting
Sonic monkey cheetah and bushy who's
monkey Cheeto is that your best friend
right now yeah
yeah I see his feet and this is and
bushy's your blanket yep and this is why
are we going to California he's your
best friend because Grandma loves them
yeah and what are we gonna do with
Grandma
in the house put her in a house you
ready to be put in your house grandma
[Music]
yeah and I'm gonna draw her in the house
no don't throw her in the house I don't
know how to draw her so I'm just
pretending like strawberry okay you're
being a comedian got it your mom's just
not funny my mistake
my mistake
so yeah today is Grandma's last day in
Vegas and she's probably really happy
because she spent like almost two months
with us now the first month was during
the summer when tiger didn't have school
we lived with her in California and then
now that we're you know we moved and we
sold our house and then Taiko was still
not in school so she helped with the
move and to watch Tycho while we were
moving since then Tiger's been in school
now for about a week and a half
um but today is Friday he does have his
neuro appointment today that's why it's
midday he's not in school
um before heading to California we're
actually gonna go see what's going on
with his brain in terms of why he's
getting these seizures
um he actually had his third seizure
this week as well
two weeks into school during music class
he just fell on the side we're not fell
but he just kind of like went down to
the floor and he had a seizure so we had
to pick him up and that was on
Wednesday
so he's not allowed to come back to
school until he gets some sort of
clearance
and then to top it off Papa over here
where's he at
oh he went downstairs that's our garage
but yeah Papa's not feeling well he's
been traveling a lot like there's just
so much going on you guys
um but things are falling back into
place and that's what I'm really focused
on things are whatever problems we're
having we're moving into the solution
phase
papa how you feeling
not very good oh damn it we're not
bringing any of your moms up not at all
no yeah yeah because you're sick okay
yeah because uh while we were cleaning
things out um my mom knows a lot of
people and there's a lot of families we
have extended family and just family
different areas that anytime I was gonna
about to throw something out she goes
hey do you want that if not I can donate
it to someone
um and and we can reuse it or repurpose
it or whatever so there's a bunch of
stuff in the garage that
we were gonna bring with us but we'll be
back to California to film some barbell
content next weekend so we'll probably
take it in that round but this round we
lose our little Papa because he's gonna
go to California and stay in California
because he has to film some yeah we got
JK news from
this time from Wednesday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday one of those
days Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I think
three days yeah yeah three days that we
have to do it
so uh yeah I might as well just stay
yeah might as well and then uh on
Saturday what was kind of cool is um we
had the whole train with bar thing yeah
where we did that giveaway a few months
back where we picked the winners and
they just train with me and hang with me
and I get to take them out to some yummy
places to eat so that's gonna be really
cool looking forward to meeting you guys
good morning
right your doctor's appointment because
little hands
hey cutie
did you have a nice little nap
that's good okay so we brought him here
to neurology center of Nevada hey hey
take it easy okay take it easy this was
highly recommended to us
um the first time around when he had his
his first ever seizure that we knew
about
um we ran a bunch of tests
that time came inconclusive so we're
gonna see her again see what we can do
to get to the bottom of this you know
what I'm saying yeah and I'm saying yeah
yeah it's been a bummer so he's on
seizure number three
according to this week yeah he had one
just a few days ago
all right so let's get this show on the
road and see what the doc gotta say
about my duty ready Duty oh nope he's
not ready at all
why you look so cute over there dude
I like little mouth movements
and there's a little CUNY come up and
catch
what are they what are they whoa you jet
what a distinguished gentleman
there's a distinguished something like
this
hi sir God you're such a boomer you
don't even know the trend what you don't
even know where that's from
you're such a distinguished gentleman
look where is it from what do you mean
you panic like you just guessed
old fart
hey I said for home is that funny
I forget you're poor and that's so funny
to you it's even funny to you wait
who's your favorite character monkey
where where's Mickey Mouse
this guy makes himself at home wherever
he goes
maybe so the last time we had his
appointment you didn't come to it no so
how does it make you feel coming back
here oh it makes me feel like every time
I miss one of his appointments it makes
me feel so bad so I want to be at all of
them so like this time I remember on
Tuesday you put in our family calendar I
was like what that's my other VA
appointment and then I texted you like
no no it's actually like on a Wednesday
or something I'm like okay Google so now
that I can make it today it makes me so
happy especially like these big ones if
it's like a checkup or whatever or if
it's very routine
um I feel like you know this this is
busy day and age
it's part of parents duties to like
multitask you know it's rough huh yeah
but when it's like big big stuff like
this like I want to be here I want to
know what's going on especially since I
know you barely know how to read you
know like you don't like you don't even
know how to like the doctor will tell
you stuff like what
peninsula you're like Peninsula what's
that how's Tiger going to eat a
peninsula that's true I'm not pre-med I
don't know I'm
smart but like I'm highly capable but
hey what's up dude those things are more
expensive than your life
well I'll tell you that's one way to
make money dude
um
I'm pretty smart but I'm also pretty
damn dumb this is one of the areas
so I know you were trying to make a joke
but joke's on you because it's true
anyways so multiple Science History
you can't break down the map
is math problem
[Music]
one of them only has one eye see it
which one has one eye the one with one
eye that one which is the bottom one or
the middle of the top one
oh no
I see one more with one eye
I think you missed it
oh yeah that one there's one more though
on that side
oh maybe it's a cupcake oh it's a
cupcake
it's the cupcake with one eye you see it
I guess someone's not good at art
oh
okay
so we just finished taika's appointment
and he's gonna go in I want to say next
week or in two weeks for an EEG scan he
already had it done we're gonna do it
again just to see what's really going on
in his brains
um they upped the dosage on his medicine
um because she was like wait so he had
another seizure and he was on medication
so that might mean that the doses is too
low but a hopeful sign is that she was
talking about you know two-thirds of
kids that start having seizures that
don't have any like conditions or
abnormalities or any type of brain
mutation or any of that stuff
um that usually two-thirds of them do
recover from it and they will you know
monitor them on medication for a year
and then slowly start winning them off
it once they see that their EEG scanner
starts coming back normal
so that's always good news
we got the duty back there getting out
of his seat Papa's barely holding on for
dear life
Tech is being extra CUNY we're gonna
make a quick little stop holy moly we're
in California we are in California a
quick stop at everyone's favorite
Eddie's world we talk about it all the
time and if you are new to this channel
and you've run and you drive by Eddie's
world you need to stop
and this is why let me show you
so who am I looking at what are the Bros
oh yeah Bros what kind of bros are we
good
tiger
[Applause]
yeah don't let them know your next move
[Music]
they never want them to be able to
predict what you're gonna
get
them
I'm not a food right now
okay while you redeemed yourself from
last time
foreign
[Applause]
this is what I'm talking about
look
candy Galore
look at this look at this
honestly I wouldn't get there any chamoy
product here it's not that good
but everything else is a banger
look at that
oh my Lord
thing and thing and banging
with this
but yeah they have they have chocolate
too
oh my God and I'm on a oh I can't have
any of this
is there anything that doesn't have
carbs or calories or
fats
water you say
Papa what does Tyga have in his hands he
has an octopus what are we gonna do with
this octopus dude
that is so cute what made you pick an
octopus I took the squid isn't it
what made you pick this guy
that's like weird stuff I always support
it because there was a turtle sea turtle
yeah normal normal and he always goes
with a weird one and I love it I support
someone that's all they're trying to get
the octopus no one wants the octopus but
it's so cool were they all octopuses
okay they're so cute is it because the
octopus can hug you with eight arms
oh my God and I was eyeing it the whole
time it was just pretzels
You're Gonna Save it yeah oh my God
you're such a genius
save it to when we can I [ __ ] love
you yeah
okay
so I
am
[Music]
chocolate covered almonds which is funny
because I don't like chocolate but right
now I'm so deprived I want it all
English toffee look at that with all
these peanuts almonds what are they
almonds ooh roasted in coconut oil oh my
God oh my God and then he got some
Berry Blue Sour Bell and I got my
chocolate covered gummy bears oh my God
I'm so excited
for some reason I feel like it's gonna
be more pretzels than Reese's peanut
butter Anis but whatever I'll dip it in
God damn [ __ ] peanut butter if I want
more peanut butter
they have a full on
selection
of crazy sounding spices as well it's
not crazy but
look at this whoop ass Carolina Reaper
[ __ ] all that you can't even teach your
food at that point why would you do that
no I'm good son
what the [ __ ] why why
so we have checked out taika got some
Snyders
which is really funny because that's
also Papa's favorite
yeah grandma likes it too look at her
going in it's the best yummy yummy oh
that one has onion or knowing it oh
she's like
oh
go for snack
snatcher I've never seen you eat one
that's why I was like wait you like
pickles like that I don't have a choice
right now but I'm I'm a grazer I'm a
muncher I love snacks I could care less
about full-on entrees and meals and
stuff just give me snacks and I'm
satisfied
hold your nose okay
I'll show you
Simon says Let It Go
at your face
okay that's your leg
[Music]
s
ah I got you
she didn't deserve it says yeah
don't touch your face so I didn't touch
my face
[Music]
okay
Moana
they're being so cute but I think since
I turned on the camera he just started
doing camera typo and he just started
being a funny guy and see if I can get
him without him
[Music]
here
not sure enough
says touch your face
stop touching your face
Simon Says touch your knees
your feet
[Music]
assignment says touch your toes
your niece
[Music]
Simon Says
[Music]
princess Simon Says
[Music]
did it
yuck
oh I'm not a baby
okay okay now listen that's your face
[Music]
and I'm obsessed at your face
your hair
it's pretty good it's really good
definitely not missing any of this what
in the what
what in the what
design you can't wait you just can't
wait that's my welcome to LA
welcome party every time I come
traffic yeah
such a hater I wanted to be the hater
today
California I love you so much but y'all
are just way too overcrowded now
I hope one day maybe I can come back but
if not I'm chilling I'll just have my
family come to me or I'll come pick them
up and then they hang up
but this is just Bonkers dude
unacceptable
okay Jokes Aside it definitely hurts me
to be bashing on my California because
I'm an L.A girl born and raised here
born and raised here California La East
L.A is always going to have my heart
just because that's all I know I hate
that I that I had to move and I hate
that I love Vegas so much I really
really do but I hope that we can be the
example of like hey if there is
something in your life that you do not
like
always have the freedom and the ability
to change it that's the underlying thing
here I hope everyone hears when I'm just
talking about your [ __ ] and I'm also
like
um I think it also comes from a place of
me just not knowing how to express my
emotions properly I'm more of like an
aggressive emotional person you know
what I mean when I'm sad I I'm more of
an angry person I'm not like
my heart's broken I'd be like nah [ __ ]
yeah you know I think it also comes from
a place of nostalgia what comes from a
place of nostalgia like when at least
when I hate on La it comes from a place
of nostalgia because it wasn't always
like this yeah so like me growing up in
the 90s being able to like ride like
three blocks down to the liquor store or
to the donut shop get a big soda
um but now like overran with like crime
and then I remember being able to drive
across uh cities so my mom would get her
Asian groceries every weekend no traffic
on the weekends yeah I remember that
it's just like knowing what La was to
where it came I think that's where the
hater rate comes from yeah well for me
it's just I don't know how to properly
express my emotions so for me what I
could be I could be more like oh man
this makes me sad because like Oh The
Nostalgia but I'm going nah after this
is what you don't mean like I'm more of
like an aggressive
emotion displayer that's all I'm saying
but I do agree with that I I do recall a
time like that
um but again
let us be the example of if you're not
happy with something you always have the
power of choice and you have the freedom
change it or even if you don't want to
change that physically maybe just the
mindset change but change is always an
option so
I'm like California why you become like
this
[Music]
ever since taika is able to do this it's
my favorite thing to witness ready
what are you doing Monkey
you're chewing gum
yeah you can have some more
you're welcome
[Music]
I could watch you chew all day my little
chick monk she's so cute
don't stop
please don't stop the music
your mom's back
your mom's back
he's crying
listen to him
she's back dude she's back
she's bad
my mom spoils these guys so much what
are you gonna give him a cookie you get
a cookie and no grandma buys you a girl
your mom buys you cookies because she
loves you so much
everyone gets a cookie and our monkey is
so excited because he's about to see his
favorite cousin
Dominic and Derek oh yeah have you
missed them oh look yeah he died because
he's a warmer he's a flash guy he's a
flash guy yeah he's a run of water he's
a runner runner yeah I'll take it out
oh
monkey Cheetos so excited
oh okay okay taika Quan is so excited
mom
nobody
where's everybody hi
where are they worthy I think they're in
there I like seeing their little highs
[Applause]
oh big hugs big hugs big hugs
yeah I have a monkey cheetah
you're so cute Papa I'm cute yes and
you're such a foodie this guy is I've
been saying it this entire video how
he's so tired and sick I have to drive
all this stuff right yeah this guy ended
up going to 99 Ranch in Monterey Park to
get food because he was craving noodles
and something stupid I'm six I don't
feel good I know but it's just so cute
because you can just order Pho or
something you know what I mean yeah but
if I get if I post means I get yelled at
so I don't do that anymore
you are a punk ass b word what
I like how I said ass but then I said b
word I caught myself yeah look at this
torture taika's leftover pizza
he's eating it like a little
bit
like a little cutie
you're the cutest all right on that note
you guys exhausted is an understatement
thank you so much love you see you
tomorrow